it kind of it kind of sucks when you
reach the point where you make a banger
video
and then you think man how am i gonna
top this if i'm not gonna top this
what's the point
i'm trying yeah exactly exactly the way
i see it is that like
uh the videos that i put out most often
are the like
the standard videos that i hope people
enjoy and that they like buy a bit of
time
yeah and then every now and then i like
to just hopefully think that
right these are the banger videos the
ones that like really blow people away
but i hope that in between then the
videos that i do put out like keep
people engaged and enjoy yeah
but that but that's not i think it's
kind of bittersweet when you do bring
out that bang of video
and it does amazing and then you're like
all right i have to upload a couple of
throwaway videos but then the throwaway
videos do just as well
just like okay yeah i can literally do
anything it'll be all right
my throwaway videos we mean videos that
take very little time
in comparison way less times because the
thing the thing that you have to get
around with being a youtuber
is that the effort you put in a video
doesn't like
hardly ever equates the views again
there's no correlation to that and you
know the
people may notice how much effort you
put in x videos
but just what what youtube cares about
the metrics
the money you make does hardly gets
effective oh yeah
it's all idea based right yeah it's all
about do you have a better idea
it doesn't matter how you execute it do
you have a better idea if you do we'll
pay you more
yeah exactly it's unfortunate but i
think i've just come to accept and i'm
totally fine with knowing that
maybe my video that i put two months of
work into
won't do well yeah i'm just happy that i
did it because i
like yeah i can at least be like i'm
capable of this it looks good on the
resume
like yeah if you were like i'm working
on a video right now where i was i was a
fiver seller for like two months
and it's all done now but that's two
months to work and if that video bombs
that's gonna be pretty sad i'm gonna cry
it's gonna be pretty [ __ ] sad isn't
it because i got
two months of two months of [ __ ] work
and then afterwards you do a video that
takes an hour
and i think i've just come to accept now
that i'm not i'm not doing it for the
views i'm doing it because i want to
make these videos that i think are cool
yeah that's pretty much where i've
gotten to now i think trash day has been
great because
it allows me to just even more further
lean into that mindset
i don't really care because we have
trash taste and and trash taste gets
more views than most of my videos and
it's just me chatting [ __ ]
yeah exactly so i gotta i gotta not give
a [ __ ] about the views yeah yeah
i've definitely started to care less on
my main channel trust trust me just care
less about the views
about the future just like i don't give
a [ __ ] about my channel
you've been like bittersweet just to see
like how much effort we put into our
videos on our own channels
then we come in chat [ __ ] for two hours
and we're like a million views
for like two hours just chatting and i'm
just like
what am i doing right and what am i
doing wrong like it's like
it's like hold on a million views and
there's only three cuts in the video
what's happening it's nice though
because it feels that like obviously
there's
we're doing something right here you
guys must enjoy it yes yeah i don't know
i think i hope so
our dynamic must be working yes i don't
know i mean i
i'm very glad that it's doing well but
but that's the thing right is that
because of trash taste because this is
quite different to what i do and what we
all do on our own channels
it's kind of incentivized me more to
explore oh yes
on my main channel like same you know i
recently brought out a video where i
kind of go personal into like my whole
thing about being happy yeah that was a
really good video yeah and it was and i
was really scared to upload that because
it's got nothing to do with anime yeah
yeah and it's just my life story
basically and i'm like i i really don't
want this to look like another sob story
like
me type of story but people really
enjoyed it and you know i asked mudan as
well to like do a little bit
different on the editing side of things
and everything turned out amazing so
when i saw that video do well i was like
okay
maybe i can even though i'm called the
anime man
maybe not every video has to be about
anime
right maybe i can go back to my let's
play days and just do whatever the [ __ ]
i want a lot of mine all about voice
acting so it's
it's fine yeah i know but at least at
least yours is just va right like you
don't have sea dog voice actor
that's true that's true not all my
videos are about the united kingdom
it's all good man it's all good yeah how
come why did you stop talking about
arizona
arizona arizona why did i not review
virginia
man what's up with that yeah i don't
know it's just uh
i don't know because with me right at
least with you guys
because your names are a lot more
general right yeah
you're not bound to a certain time i
mean i feel like i am have you ever
thought about changing your name
i have in in a sense yes uh
actually a number of times i thought
about it like when i when i was still
doing let's plays
i thought about changing it just because
first of all half of the games i play
aren't even anime right
second of all i'm uploading like five
let's plays
in a week and two anime videos so i
thought is that really a point to call
myself the anime man but at that point
now the anime man is just a brand yeah
true people know me
not as joey but as the anime man yeah
yeah so it's really hard to just
suddenly
change the name because i've seen
instances of youtubers who have already
established the name
who decide on a whim to change their
username to something because it doesn't
fit their current image
yeah and it's never worked out i i know
i know one channel i think it's worked
out there was a channel called uh
he goes by lemme know now have you seen
his videos oh yeah
he used to be a top 10 channel
my god let me know like he basically now
he basically just does
[ __ ] netflix documentaries now that's
that's kind of like the level
of youtube content that he looks like
really good stuff yeah really
but yeah it used to be called top tens
yeah and uh obviously
he's not doing top 10 it's now i think
he might do them
every now and then i don't think he does
though right but yeah he changed his
name and i remember
i remember being like weirded out at
first i was like what why
yeah but now you don't give a [ __ ] yeah
yeah but that's the thing right i feel
that is just
a really small handful true yeah yeah
most of the time you just like oh
god why did their name change why would
you be resetting all the seo
yeah why are they why they're making
completely different content i i didn't
sign up for this [ __ ] i mean
like respect to anyone who has the balls
to do that because i wouldn't be able to
get away from
like my brand that i've built up yeah
over this entire time right you know
like that's like if for example right
like you took away va in your name
yeah right and you just turn it to sea
dog i don't think it would change
anything
i don't know man i think it might i i
think it's more like if you just change
your name to like connor
yeah yeah yeah true yeah that's why but
that's the reason why like
for me for example i want to like say on
trash taste right i just want to be
established as
joey the anime man yeah yeah right
because i feel that's a completely
different side of me
yeah because in the cl you've got yeah
you're guarding the clips aren't you now
right yeah yeah
because we had a discussion when we were
making the channel we were like so
in the clips are we calling us the anime
man and
did xx thing or like joey yeah
i think i think i i i was at the mindset
of like okay well
it's a podcast and it's very personal
and we're probably gonna be talking
about personal things i think it should
be connor
joey et cetera yeah it's like and not to
say that we don't mind you guys calling
us by our usernames right yeah
but i think the end game for trash
tastes at least in my mind
is that i don't want to be known as the
anime man gear can see
dog i wanted us to be known as joey
garten and conor of trash yeah
yeah the boys the boys right